it really is an amazing privilege to
have a avery give a talk at our workshop
today
so aveem is a professor at the
toyota technological institute at
chicago and uh she's done a lot of like
amazing work in like too many areas to
list but i'll still try to make them
i
still like to
count them out so theoretical machine
learning i'll go through game theory
online algorithms approximation
algorithms and so on so forth and
today he'll be talking about learning
and intersections with fairness
thank you so much abram and uh
the floor is yours
thank you um
thank you for the nice introduction and
it's a pleasure to be here
virtually i wish i could be there in
person
so but oh well next time
so
yeah so
i'm going to talk about
a few pieces of work in the area of
learning incentivizing improvement and
fairness in the presence of strategic
agents
and this is joint work with sava ahmadi
uh hedya baihagi and kazia nagita
saba and hedya are postdocs and kazee is
a student here
okay let me get started
make sure this works
okay so uh
yeah so the first thing i want to talk
about is work uh on strategic online
classification and uh this is coming
from a paper the strategic perceptron
that we wrote is in uh
ec21
so
uh good
um so the problem we'll be looking at is
kind of you know in the in the context
of this workshop so we'll be interested
in classifying entities that will aim to
modify how they appear in order to be
labeled as positive say for getting a
loan college admission something like
that and so we will have a you know a
mathematical model where
agents can modify their feature values
at some cost and some very particular
notion of utility for these agents
um and then we're going to try analyze
algorithms in this model
and the challenge is that as you learn
and modify your decision rule agents are
going to change how they respond this is
going to be an online setting and so
this this problem is going to be
particularly a challenge in an online
non-distributional setting so we are
going to have agents coming one at a
time who are not coming from some
distribution so
we can't for example have a training
phase where we collect real
unmanipulated data by for instance
accepting everyone at the beginning
solving for a rule then modifying it
we're going to always have to be you
know trying to figure out you know what
do we get from the behave from the thing
we saw
so it'll be an informational problem in
addition to a computational problem
and it's a lot like online learning of a
stackelberg leader strategy except it's
new agents coming in one at a time
okay so so all this you know falls under
the category different sorts of names
for it but one i like is measure
management and this is a nice book that
i i like called what counts and what
gets counted that kind of
gets at this issue of the difference
between the thing you care about namely
what counts and the way you are
measuring it and what gets counted and
you know has a variety of a lot of
anecdotes of places where it's something
you care about but of course you're
measuring people and these people will
uh if they're their performance is being
measured according to these measures
they're going to modify the measurement
without actually necessarily modifying
in the way you want it the thing you
care about and this goes under a number
of
names like campbell's law good hearts
law and so forth okay anyway so that's
the topic of the workshop um but so here
now let me get to a very specific
mathematical model that we are going to
be focusing on here
okay so it's um
model is as follows we're going to be
interested in binary classification
problems so
you know say deciding whether someone
gets a loan or not our data point are
going to be points in d-dimensional
space so each individual described by d
real valued features and we're imagining
the true data is linearly separable so
something like this picture here say the
blues are positives and the greens are
negative
and the agents uh arrive the data points
one at a time
our classifier makes a decision plus or
minus on them and then we are told the
correct answer did we get it right or
not so this is a classic online learning
model and our goal is to minimize the
number of mistakes so we get a data
point we have to predict positive or
negative we're told the right answer
we're charged one dollar say if we get
it wrong we want to minimize the number
of mistakes
the twist here is that our agents are
strategic and we will assume they have
the ability to
in particular to move themselves in
space by a limited amount in say an l2
or weighted l1 ball so l1 would
correspond to cost to changing
individual feature values l2 is more of
a you know
combined movement cost and and their
goal is to be classified as positive
more so for example this green point
here maybe it can move in this yellow
ball
okay and we'll imagine that agents have
a linear cost to move
and they get benefit one from a positive
classification
uh and their utility maximizers so what
it means this is for the ball they can
move at a cost one they could move
farther but that would have cost more
than one so it wouldn't be worth it
we'll assume the agents know the current
classification rule that we're using so
it's a it's a purely it's a completely
transparent system we are trying to give
out loans we completely specify
the the rule for you know what does it
mean to have a good enough
credit score and you know agents can
move to try to get on to the positive
side of it if
they can
and so in particular if the
classification rules deterministic which
it will be in all the algorithms we're
going to look at then agents will only
manipulate if it actually changes their
classification from minus to plus
because otherwise why put in the effort
so we're assuming there's a linear cost
to move and if they can do so they will
do it in the cheapest way possible so
for example this green point here would
move perpendicular to the red line and
stop that's what they would do because
that's the cheapest way to become
classified as possible
all right the setting makes sense so
this is that's the setting
okay
all right and so this is actually
similar to settings that a number of
folks have looked at in particular one
of dong at all except in our case our
losses are not convex or continuous and
so as a result we are only going to be
able to nicely handle what's called the
realizable case where there's really a
true linear separator
in particular what's happening what
makes this challenging is that you know
the agents just care about being
classified positive they don't care
about their dot product with our
classification really just want to be
bigger than whatever the threshold is to
make it positive so um you know if if
it's if they can't do it they won't move
at all and if they can they'll they'll
do it the cheapest way possible okay so
that's the setting
all right let's let's look at this
problem uh well okay so first just kind
of some related work has been quite a
lot i'll just mention a few so work of
heart megiddo papamitra and wooders
considered a distributional case they
actually looked at different sorts of
costs costs that are separable that in
some sense actually make the problem
easier because it's such a powerful
strategic setting that there's much
in some sense all you can do is solve a
one-dimensional problem in their case
but it's kind of interesting that
strategic behavior could make a problem
easier by limiting the sort of
reasonable things you can do the work of
dong and i'll look at an online regret
setting with convex losses and different
agent utility functions and then another
nice piece of work i'd like to mention
is work of chen liu and paramata and
they consider a less predictable model
for agents a little bit more like
adversarial machine learning and so the
associated benchmark is different than
their kids
okay
so with that let me just kind of give an
example of a challenge that comes up
here so let's imagine here's a simple
world with three data points they are
linearly separable and let's imagine our
agents can manipulate in an l2 ball of
radius a half
and let's see what would happen if we
ran a classic online learning algorithm
in particular the perceptron algorithm
so what is that algorithm how does it
work well the way that algorithm works
is it starts by predicting negative
until it sees its first positive example
and it sets its weight vector to equal
that example so like here so we're
starting off the weight vector one zero
and we're going to predict with w of x
greater than or equal to zero that's
going to be our classifier so the purple
line is our classifier
and now maybe this negative example
comes along and it's real location is
negative point five comma one but it's
going to manipulate it sees that hey in
order to get a loan it has to move to
the right and so it will do that because
it can and so we will actually see it
over here we won't actually see it where
it is and we will make a mistake because
it's a negative example so what do we do
we subtract that negative example from
our weight vector to get this new wave
vector here one comma minus one okay so
we've just subtracted that point
now along comes this positive example
now this positive example
it
would like to be classified positive but
it's too far to move this is root two
over two distance and it can only move a
half so it'll just stay where it is it's
not going to move because it can't move
that far so it'll stay where it is so we
will now see a positive at 0 1 which is
the exact same location as the negative
we just saw we will add it to our weight
vector and get back to here and this if
these two points repeat over and over
then we're just going to keep back and
forth back and forth doing this
when really there was a perfectly good
solution
this here for example is a perfectly
good solution because this is a linear
separator where the positive can
manipulate that's less than a half but
the negative can't it's more than a half
so this would actually classify
everybody correct
notice that the the
correct solution here may require
manipulation okay so it's just like you
know when you're reading recommendation
letters
right excellent means great great means
good and good means not very good right
so you just you know you understand that
so so the correct answer is going to
require the manipulation
okay
so
the standard perceptron algorithm didn't
work and and you can call have show the
same phenomena will also occur with l1
manipulation as well
okay
all right so so that's just to kind of
show a little bit about where the
problems are um
so let's see how we can solve this
problem
okay so we're going to
come up with a
strategy manipulation aware strategy
aware algorithm we'll call the strategic
perceptron and let's
take the case of l2 manipulation so
agents can move with an l2 ball of some
radius r
and let's assume that radius r is known
to us
if it's not known to us we can
wrap around a binary search and i'll say
a little bit about that so we don't
actually have to know in advance but
it's just a little easier to assume that
we know it in advance and again this is
a very stylized model if it wasn't clear
already
all the agents are identical in terms of
their ability to manipulate everyone has
the same radius r it's all an exact l2
ball
okay
so for example this agent here
that negative example could manipulate
anywhere in say a ball of radius you
know a half something like that
we will assume that there exists a
perfect classifier in the event w start
at x or equal to zero in the event there
is no manipulation so something like
this okay
and so one thing that means is if you
just shift it by r units you will get a
perfect classifier in the presence of
manipulation so if everybody can move a
distance r if you knew with a right
answer for agents that did not
manipulate all you have to do
is instead of looking at w star at x
squared equal to zero you just shift it
over by r units which is this is this is
shifting it over by our units to get the
blue line
and now that will be a perfectly fine
classifier in the presence of
manipulation because we've moved by r so
all the people to the right of the
purple line can move to the right of the
blue line and all the folks to the left
of the purple line can't move to the
right of the blue line right so that
negative can no longer move there but
the positive example can't
okay does that make sense
so we could so if we knew the right
answer it would be easy to handle this
manipulation we would just shift it over
so if we had access to clean
unmanipulated data we could just solve
there and then just say okay you know
great means good whatever and just shift
it over by by however much okay
and so our goal is to find a weight
vector that's close to this w star so
that we can kind of do the same thing
all right any questions at this point
all right good so
so how are we going to do this so for
those of you familiar with the
perceptron algorithm there's a certain
basically any online learning algorithm
every time it makes a mistake it has to
make progress
in this model you you don't have to
learn from your non-mistakes but you
better learn from your mistakes because
you're trying to keep your mistakes down
and in particular the thing the
algorithm needs to make progress so this
will be familiar to you if you know the
algorithm if you're not familiar with
the algorithm analysis don't worry about
it the thing you need is some point
so given the mistake on some x you want
to be able to update using sum x tilde
so sum x tilde that could be x itself or
not with two properties it should have a
positive dot product with the true w
star
by the zero or negative dot product with
your hypothesis vector doubled if you
can find such next tilde
you can update by adding it to your w
that's actually all the algorithm does
and that will be enough to get a good
mistake down
okay so that's the thing we need
and so
what i want to do now is go through well
how are we going to get those things and
and so to analyze this there will be
four cases of which the first three are
trivial and all the work will be in the
last case but let's go through them one
at a time
so let's start in the usual way we will
predict negative till we see the first
positive example x
it's positive so it has a positive dot
product of w star it has a zero dot
product with our weight vector w because
it was our weight vector was basically
the all zeros vector we add it so now
our we initialize with our weight vector
being that example x itself great
and now we will predict by using
that w of x squared equals zero but
shift it over by our units so we will
use the blue line as our classifier
so now what do we do if we make a
mistake
using this blue line as the blue
hyperplane really as a classifier
right
the green thing is a vector the blue
thing is the perpendicular hyperlink
okay
so first of all easy case number one
suppose you make a pot a mistake on a
positive example x that is to the left
of the purple line w x is less than or
equal to zero well then we can update
using it directly this point x did not
manipulate there would be no reason to
manipulate and still be classified
negative so that point really has a
positive dot product of w star it is a
true positive example so it satisfies
this first condition
and it's to the left of the purple line
purple hyperplane so it satisfies this
condition so we can update using it
directly great
now what about making a mistake on the
positive point that's to the right of
the purple
like here
that would satisfy this first condition
but
not the second one because it has
actually a positive dot product with our
current vector w so this would be a
problem luckily this should never happen
why well because if this was the true
unmanipulated location he would have
moved to here
because it's distance less than r and if
it wasn't the true location what's it
doing manipulating to some point where
it's still being classified negative
that makes no sense it's not a rational
thing to do so
the point should there should never be
any example there in fact if you see an
example there what that means is that if
you thought people could move this far
they really can't because he would have
moved if he could so that means your
guess for ours is too big and you can
use this in the binary search in the
case that you don't actually know in
advance how far people can manipulate
okay good so this case would be
problematic but luckily it should never
happen so we don't have to worry about
it
okay
third case also an easy case is a
negative example that is strictly to the
right of the blue line the blue
hyperplane if you're strictly to the
right then that means that that point
did not manipulate because why would you
move farther than you had to so that
means it's a true negative it's a true
negative it means you can flip it
through the origin to make it that a
true positive an x delta that will
indeed be a true positive and it's to
the left of the purple hyperplane so it
satisfies this condition so great
so there's only one case left to go
which is a negative example that's
exactly on our blue hyperplane it might
have manipulated we're not sure
so what will we do well we know it moved
the direction of moves which is
perpendicular to the blue hyperplane so
we can and it moved at most the distance
r let's pull it all the way back
by distance r
it maybe didn't it may have come from in
the middle but let's just pull all the
way back flip that through the origin
and update using that
so that point x tilde satisfies this by
design it's on the blue hyperplane so
it's dot product of w is zero
but why does it satisfy this condition
here
well the reason is because of a property
that i haven't said yet which is that by
induction the algorithm maintains the
property that the current weight vector
w always has a positive or at least
non-negative dot product with the true
vector w star and what that means is
that even if we subtract a little bit
too much here we're subtracting a little
bit more times w so so what's going on
they originally came from somewhere here
we pulled it back a little bit too far
but by subtracting a little bit more of
w that only made it more negative than
where it really was it was really here
and was negative for w star you pull it
back you subtract the little w it only
becomes more negative for w star so when
you flip it through the origin it's only
more positive and so it still satisfies
this condition that we want
okay so that's that's how this analysis
works
okay and so yeah so you could so this
that gives you a bound that this
algorithm makes actually not too much
more mistakes than the standard
perceptron makes unless the standard
non-strategic case
okay so that's a nice statement and then
we can extend this to known weighted l1
costs the difference in the l1 setting
is that in l2 agents will move
perpendicular to your separator and l1
they will move along a coordinate axis
whichever one is giving you the most
bang for the buck so as you modify the
separator they might move on the x1 they
might move in x2 whichever way
gives you the most bang for the buck
that's the way l1 movements work
and
if you know the costs so you know that
say moving horizontally is twice as
expensive as moving vertically you can
use that in your current weight vector
to determine the direction they came
from not necessarily how far but at
least the direction and that's good
enough when we can do the same analysis
we've done so far okay
for unknown costs we're currently
exponential number of unknowns
so okay so that's the end of the first
part of my talk i just want to mention
before going to the next part
one
two nice open problems
so
here's a problem which you know i think
is interesting and kind of
you know i think it's a nice question is
can you extend this to a bound in terms
of the hinge loss
of the
okay step back i made the assumption
that the original non-manipulated data
was perfectly separable in the
non-strategic case the perceptron
algorithm and things like svm
they all can give you a bound in terms
of the hinge loss of the
data it's
not how many
mistakes the best separator makes but
rather it's more like how far you'd have
to move the points to put them on the
correct side by a nice margin okay
that's the hinge loss
and
can you extend that to the strategic
case so can you get a bound in terms of
the hinge loss of the original
unmanipulated data now just to be clear
here that one thing that's trivial to do
is to get a bound in terms of the hinge
loss of the observed data so if you look
at the data you see and say gosh what
would be the best will be the separator
of smallest hinge loss for the data you
saw
yes you can get a mistake bound in terms
of that in fact that follows from the
direct from the standard perceptron
algorithm analysis because the standard
perceptron algorithm doesn't care where
how the points got created it just gives
you a bound in terms of the points you
see but it's not so meaningful because
it could be that the reason there is no
good separator of low hinge loss is
because your algorithm was bad jumping
around all the time causing people to
move around all sorts of different ways
and they're so therefore there's not a
good separator but had you behaved
differently there would have been a
separator with low hinge loss the
algorithm i gave handles that in the
case that yeah how do you behave
differently there would have been an
algorithm with zeroing but if it's not
zero that analysis breaks down and if
you want to know where it breaks down it
can be fooled by even a single bad
example the very beginning and that
single bad example will break this
inductive assumption that you have a
non-negative dot product with w star and
once you break that it can
you know a bad sequence can continue to
have you pointed in the wrong direction
you think you're making progress but
you're really not of course you can fix
that problem by restarting the algorithm
but that doesn't really fix it just that
particular example because then what if
you get another method in any case we do
not know
about in terms of the hinge loss of the
original data i think that would be
really interesting
another nice question is can you get
meaningful bounds for the kernelized
setting one nice thing with svms
perceptron and all that is that you can
kernelize them however kernelization
breaks the idea that people are moving
an l2 ball because that's not an l2 ball
in the kernel space anymore and so kind
of all hell breaks loose and we don't
know how to make things work anyway
okay good so now let me move on to the
next
i'm going to talk about two more things
briefly
okay
um
good so the next type of topic i want to
talk about is combining gaming and
improvement this is also all of this was
work joining with saba hedya and kezia
okay so
um
good so
we've assumed that agents are you know
just manipulating they're just gaming
they're not actually changing their true
locations but you can imagine that some
directions correspond to kind of
manipulation or gaming but others are
true improvement for instance maybe you
have a loan criteria that puts some
weight on having taken a money
management class it's an action you can
take that will actually improve perhaps
your ability you know to or the chance
that you will pay back that loan
okay so that could actually improve you
and make you a little worthy
okay and in general there's been a lot
of recent interest i just listed some
papers here in models that combine
gaming with true improvement a lot of
really nice work
uh in our setting we are going to
consider a goal so think of you know
bank giving out loans of maximizing true
positives so
pauses that you correctly classify as
positive these are loans given out to
qualified applicants
subject to few false positives so loans
given out to unqualified activists okay
so that's the kind of goal we're going
to think of right something you might
imagine the bank wants to do they want
to give out loans to qualified
applicants because they want to you know
that's how they make money but they
don't want to give out loans to
unqualified applicants
and what's interesting about this goal
if you think about it is even a perfect
classifier might be sub-optimal if it
doesn't incentivize people
so
imagine for example that nobody is
qualified for a loan okay you can
correctly classify everybody but you
won't be giving out any loans you'd be
better off if there's some way that you
can
incentivize people to become loan worthy
by taking that money management class so
that you can actually give them out a
loan because that's how the bank makes
money
okay so so it's kind of an interesting
setting because
being a perfect classifier isn't that
maybe you might still be leaving you
know
positives on the table
you know potential causes something
and so we'll look at this problem in the
backseat and we actually look at two
versions of this and i'll kind of
briefly mention each
the first version is a linear model
where we think of again points in rd the
true decision boundary is a linear
separator
we'll think of some directions as being
gaming directions and some as
improvement directions we'll imagine l1
costs to increase coordinate values so
decreasing is free so you know if we're
going to measure some quantity there's a
it's easy for free you can look worse
than you really are
okay
the algorithms classifier may or may not
be a linear separator okay so we can
allow
just
well imagine that there is a true linear
separator but you know the algorithms
classified could be whatever it wants
and so just to let me just show an
example of something that you know kind
of interesting can happen here so let me
unpack this picture this is a
two-dimensional picture uh improvement
is to the right and gaming is up and
maybe improving cost twice as much as
gaming in this example there are three
data points circled here in purple x1 x2
x3 and this is where they live and then
f star is the true
correct classifier and that classifier
is correctly classifying x1 and x2 is
negative and x3 is positive
now in the presence of manipulation this
wouldn't do great because x1 and x2
let's imagine that the manipulation
budget is fairly large they could move
straight up if they wanted to
because gaming is in this example twice
as cheap as improvement so they would
move up rather than to the right and
they would gain and be classified
positive if they really aren't now of
course you could fix that by just
shifting the separator
parallel to itself as far as needed so
that the these you know x1 x2 can no
longer gain but x3 can and so you know
however far it takes to to you know
based on the cost
you could do that and that would
correctly classify everybody we
correctly classify x3 is positive and
correctly classify x 1 x 2 is negative
but that's maybe leaving money on the
table instead if you were to use this
non-linear shaped region shaded here in
kind of gray
let's see what happens now if we look at
x2 over here it has a choice to move to
the right or move up but it's twice as
far to move up as to the right so it
would rationally decide to move to the
right
and actually become positive because
that's true improvement
x1 over here we'll do a combination
it'll move to the right and up and we've
written i've written here kind of
it starts off at x1 and it it moves to
the right and then the moving up part is
just gaming so our classifier sees this
that's
the perk is for its perceived location
but really it's sitting here because the
upward movement was just gaming but
nonetheless that's a true positive and
so it actually improved itself enough to
become positive then x3 would just
improve itself to become here so this
classifier would actually allow you to
give out you know three good loans so it
would correctly classify everyone and
classify them as positive which is
better than just correctly classifying
them the way they were originally
does the example make sense
okay good so um
yeah so that's kind of the problem is is
how can we do this so
uh
so a couple you know results i think
there's a you know a lot open here that
we don't know but just a few things that
we that we were able to figure out one
is that in two dimensions you can indeed
efficiently solve for a solution that
maximizes
true positives subject to no false
positives like like this picture here
but in general d this is npr
in fact it's even empty hard in general
d to determine if you can incentivize
incentivize everyone to become positive
on the other hand you can efficiently
find a linear classifier that
incentivizes everyone to become positive
if such a linear classifier exists in
general d that's that you can do with
linear programming
okay so those are just a few statements
um
and then i would mention another model
we looked at which is in some sense more
general but in some sense less
we call a general discrete model and
here
we imagine that space is discretized
into end pieces like in this picture
here and the classifier can label any
subset of them positive and the rest
negative so here we've labeled five of
them blue positive and four of them red
is negative
and then for any given agent and then
the true classifier could be that the
true function could be anything at all
um and now for any given agent i and any
given piece j
moving to piece j has some cost c i j
and may or may not make the agent truly
positive so in this general model where
we imagine the true classifier can
really be anything
and our
what our algorithm can do is just label
some subset of these n pieces as
positive we can view this as the
following bipartite graph problem we
have n agents over here on the left
little n agents capital n pieces over
here on the right and for every agent on
the left it has some cost to move into
each piece so cij to move for agent i to
move to piece j and that movement might
involve some combination of gaming and
improvement that may or may not make the
agent truly qualified for the loan so
let's color the edge
blue if it actually makes the agent
qualified and color the edge
red if it doesn't so we have a bipartite
weighted graph with the edges having two
colors blue and red where blue
corresponds to yes that's made the agent
qualified red corresponds to no it
didn't make the agent qualify so like in
this particular example maybe agent two
was already qualified and so it doesn't
matter if they'll stay they'll stay
qualified no matter what they do
but agents one and three initially were
not qualified they might or might not
become qualified for alone depending on
which piece they move to okay
all right so that's the setting and then
our goal is to pick a subset of nodes on
the right hand side so that what so if
each agent on the left moves to its
cheapest neighbor
in in the subs that we picked so it take
does the cheapest you know the cheapest
way can get qualified for a loan or it
does move to none of them if they're all
too expensive maybe all the options are
beyond its budget so it just does
nothing
if that happens we would like as many
blue edges to show up and not too many
red edges so the blue edges all
correspond to people that we give out
loans to who are qualified and the red
edges taken are people we gave out loans
to we're not qualified yet okay so
that's what we want so this is our
general a very general model but it kind
of requires discretization
and so one thing nice here is yeah
maximizing blue subject to no red that
can be solved efficiently and what's
interesting about the solution is it's
actually point wise optimal meaning that
if someone doesn't get a loan you can
say well sorry you didn't get the loan
but actually there was no way for me to
give you a loan without also giving out
a loan to somebody who wasn't qualified
okay
and and also of mint cost
so mean total amount of effort
done
by the agent uh on the other hand
maximizing blue is subject to most k red
edges to take in this npr
okay so those few things you can say
all right
and
uh
another nice thing you can well another
thing you can ask here is uh what about
learning from data so i assumed here
that we had up front all the agents all
their edges all the costs and we're
gonna algorithmically you know you take
in this input you know all the things
about the people and
have this whole graph in front of you
and you're trying to figure out what to
do but what if you don't have the graph
in front of you well
let's imagine there is a probability
distribution d over agents so what does
that mean it's some probability
distribution over
nodes on the left what's a node on the
left it's a it's really a
it's um
kind of a vector
of costs and colors right like it's a
distribution over what's an agent an
agent is something that has cost to go
to each piece on the right and colors
for each other so it's a
it's kind of a just a vector of cost
color pairs over the end pieces so with
this but there's some probability
distribution over them and we can
imagine a full information model where
we see all their out edges so that's
kind of like we get a focus group we pay
you know 20 people that come into our
laboratory we ask them lots of questions
and we figure out you know this graph
or we can imagine a natural partial
information model which is
you know
all you can do is pick some subset of
the right-hand side this is more like
online learning you pick some you're
going to pick you say okay you're
qualified for the loan if you satisfy
condition one or condition three but not
two and four okay so you pick the subset
one three and then an agent comes along
and you see where they go
they they satisfy condition one and if
their edge was blue or red you gave them
a loan and did they pay you back so
you you you see it's just like the
online mistake bound model except we're
assuming they come from a distribution
okay so
you all you can do the only access you
have is you pick some nodes on the right
some agent comes along they take an edge
you see where they landed and whether
they actually became truly qualified or
not
and then the goal is to find a subset of
nodes on the right hand side that gets
you
a large probability mass of true
positive say within some epsilon of some
optimal and that most epsilon
probability mass of false positives
where our notion of optimal the thing
we're comparing to is the best you can
hope to do subject to zero false
positives so this is a bi-criterion we
are going to find a solution that is
nearly as good in terms of true
positives with a most epsilon false
positive rate
uh with respect to the optimum that has
a zero false positive right
okay and it turns out you can achieve
that in both the full and partial
information models
um okay
and and basically it is an online
all right good so
um so let me now just turn to the the
last topic i want to mention is about
fairness and helping agents improve so
so far we were talking about
the improvement we didn't actually you
know we cared about giving out loans we
weren't really trying to sort of improve
agents quality other than making them
you know qualified to give out the loans
that we have to give out
uh okay but now we're going to be
looking at the problem of fear of
fairness and helping agents improve
so we're going to there's going to be
much simpler in some ways we'll be
looking at just a one-dimensional
problem here so let's consider the
following one-dimensional problem we
have a collection of agents and they
each have a single
real valued skill level so these are
maybe employees at some company and they
have
you know some skill level and
it's just one dimensional or it's you
know students with some
uh
just think of it like an
sat score kind of things that we imagine
we've compiled everything down to a
single number which of course is
unrealistic but
hey
you know start with one right so we have
a um
a single one-dimensional skill level
and what we can do so what the kind of
action we can take is we can select k
targets and think of these as like
projects or trainings these will be
points on the line like here
three targets so i think these are like
projects or trainings that if you do it
you will
it will help it will improve your skill
okay you can think of them as tests so
we're gonna pay you a hundred dollars
for passing a test
and let's imagine that every agent i
they will
choose the closest target greater than
where they are if it's within some
distance delta otherwise they do nothing
so in this case
um if there if there is a project or
training or a test that is you know
it has to be challenging has to be above
their current skill level but not too
much above if it's more than delta they
can't do it so this person here
unfortunately
has no
tests they can take that's above their
level but within delta this person has
nothing they can take that's above but
everybody else is able to improve to the
value of that test that project or
training
so the total improvement is the sum of
the lengths of all the blue arrows
that's how much improvement happens here
okay so we were able to put down some
targets these are challenges or tests or
targets or projects and agents will
do the the
we'll assume that each agent will pick
the easiest one to do that's above their
level and we'll do that and improve up
to that level
so that's the model and our goal is to
maximize total improvement and to do it
in a fair way once we introduce fairness
okay so that's that's the problem this
is very closely related to a paper on
algorithms and learning for fear
portfolio design where you're trying to
put portfolios
slightly below where people are but
there's an interesting non-monotonicity
in our setting here that
make that makes the problem different
and also makes the fairness issue a
little tricky
okay
so what do we mean by fairness here
there's multiple things one could mean
and i'm just going to pick two things
that that one could mean
so first of all let's imagine there are
multiple groups so for instance there's
a green group and the purple group we
can see see here the purple group is
being helped a lot more than the green
group because it's only one green agent
and they're moving about this much and
whereas
all the purple agents are improving a
good amount
so we have two of the green agents
aren't being helped at all
so we would like to help each group
fairly so what what could that mean so a
few things we might mean one easy notion
is min max fairness so maximize the
minimum over the groups of the total and
group movement group g so this solution
here the minimum group would be the
green group and they're helped by a
single blue arrow of this length so
that's how much improvement they get the
purple group gets more and so from that
perspective you'd want to move these
guys around to help the green group more
now one issue with min max or max min
fairness is
um
it could be that there is some group
that's just
very hard to help they're all spread out
whereas another group is very it's you
know pretty concentrated and so this
would sort of force you to use almost
all your resources on the one group
that's hard to help and end up not
helping the other group very much at all
so so another notion we look at
and i think it's kind of more
interesting in this context is the
following can we give the following
guarantee that for each group we will
help that group by within a constant
factor of the most we could possibly
help that group if that group was the
only group we cared about okay so we'll
tell the green folks you know we will
give you within a constant factor of the
most that you could get if you are the
only people that matter and we'll tell
the the purple group the same thing okay
so
uh can you give you know within a
constant factor of what you could hope
to do if you used all your resources on
that group
and the answer is yes as long as there's
a constant number of groups
and one of the chat and i'll get to that
in a second but a challenge here that's
what i mentioned is there is a kind of
trivial way to try to solve this problem
if there's two groups
and you know our big o is say you know
we're willing to be within a factor of
two or four or something say two
you could say all right i'll just use
half my resources on the green group and
half my resources on the purple group so
if i've got four targets i'll use two of
them for purple and two for green and
i'll i'll help each group within a
factor of two i should mention it's this
is some you know
some modular or
convex adding the the the extra benefit
of another target that keeps dropping
right so it's it's um yeah
so you could you could do that you could
say let me just use half my resources
for one half for the other and that
would be fine except for one problem
which is that there's a there is a
non-monotonicity here which is adding a
target can actually reduce improvement
so if for instance i were to add this
green
target here
with the goal of helping that green
agent then all of a sudden that purple
one over here
is going to improve less because they
now have a simpler you know less
challenging test if we kind of you know
if we simplify the test to help
some people that might hurt others
because now they're not challenged so
much and so they don't improve as much
as they would otherwise so actually in
this
in this context you can't if you take
uh if you find the optimal solution for
one group the opposite of the other and
then overlay them that could actually be
a really horrible solution for one
or both of the groups
so so you can't just do that
um okay
but so the main technical result we have
here though is that if the number of
targets is at least number of groups
there always exists a solution this is a
structural statement there always exists
a solution that has the property that it
gives each group within a one over
polynomial the number of groups fraction
of the maximum possible improvement you
could hope to give that group
and then once you have that structural
statement now you can just go ahead do
dynamic programming to find the pareto
curve of solutions and extract out the
solution that says that that has the
property you want okay so so you could
so actually this is a problem where
finding is not the problem that they
just do dynamic programming get the
whole pareto curve the problem is
showing that there exists a solution
that actually has those properties
okay and then you can get generalization
guarantees for this this is on the
assumption you have the agents what if
you don't what if you have a sample
using techniques of balkan dick and
others you can get generalization
guarantees for this
okay so so that's uh those are the
things i want to talk about so just kind
of summarize i looked at the
talk about three problems one is a
strategic classification with the
perceptron algorithm and i
introduced the strategic perceptron
algorithm here it achieves nearly the
same guarantees in the strategic setting
as the standard perceptron algorithm
does in the non-strategic case at least
for the realizable for you know data
that's actually linearly inseparable we
also looked at the case that agents can
both game and improve and in that case
our strongest results are in this
general discrete model and
two-dimensional linear model
and we also looked at a one-dimensional
model where the goal is to help agents
improve and we consider a fairness goal
of helping each group within a constant
factor of the most we could possibly
help if we'd allocate all our resources
to that group and the tricky issue here
is it's non-mods
and then just to mention
two
nice open problems one is can you get
good bounds in the strategic perceptron
case
in terms of the hinge loss of the
unmanipulated data
and we have a counter example to the
algorithm we have and we don't know a
good algorithm for that and can get good
bounds in the kernel accident
and that's it
did you ever uh questions from the
audience
thanks for the talk i was i was
wondering if you can help me understand
a little bit more like what your
long-term vision for this research
project is
and in particular are we hoping to
create algorithms that are deployed
are we hoping to gain kind of
conceptual insights
and what types of algorithms or insights
would be or something else be kind of
hoping to to develop here
okay yeah it's a great question i mean
as a theoretician my interest mainly is
that uh
you know
what is to try to see if we can get
insights into
the idea of classifying
you know applying machine learning to
entities that will respond right and
that is what
and uh
in particular is interesting in the
online case where
um in an offline case where you could
you know say well let me just get some
real clean data maybe solve and then
just move my solution the online case is
interesting because you never
quite get real data so um you know so
how do we do that so i think that's um
just a question of what's like is what's
doable like can you sell you know is
this
do uh the kernels work with strategic
agents or not i mean it just seems like
a very puzzling questionnaire
in fact even the simplest thing like a
norm okay the very simplest trick in the
normal perceptron is using non-zero
thresholds right if you want to have a
linear separate it doesn't go through
the origin it's trivial you add an extra
feature you set the one and everything
now you have one more coordinate you go
through zero in the new space which is
going through a non-zero in the original
space
that reduction doesn't work here because
they can't manipulate the new ones
they're not moving in a l2 ball anymore
and so you you can still solve that
problem
but it's more painful so it's kind of
you know well what are the tools out
there okay the reductions the standard
reductions are failing are there other
reductions here so i think this is a lot
of interesting you know it's kind of
like
when so it's kind of an analog of saying
gosh
you know looking another complexity
measure almost you know we have
strategic agents how does that
all the algorithmic tools that we have
how does this affect them so that's
that's one interest i think another one
so
in a maybe more
social well you know level the one thing
i think is nice is the notion of
transparency so
although this um strategic
you know model is very stylized everyone
can move and there's balls
one thing it relies on is the assumption
that the agents you know everything is
public the agents know the classifier
you're using and that's kind of nice
because
my hope would be that if you can
actually deploy algorithms that are
strategy aware that will then
incentivize the
deployers the the loan givers and so
forth to actually make their rules
public because one reason you might want
to keep things private is that you're
worried people might you know manipulate
them but if you have something a
strategy aware then you know then
there's in fact you're relying on people
manipulating you so you want to make
them transparent in public so maybe this
is some way of improving transparency by
having a model where really to do well
as a decide as the decision maker
god i almost said decider as a decision
maker um
for the
younger folks won't get that um then uh
uh you know you want to get transparency
you know in the system
hi you might have just answered my
question actually but i was um thinking
back to i think the first and the second
stories
and i think you were assuming that the
agents were
strate fully strategic and rational
and that they had knowledge of the
decision boundary that's right right so
my kids are applying to college now and
i'm working very hard to manipulate them
and i do not have knowledge of the
decision boundary unfortunately so i was
thinking about that while you were
giving that person but maybe what you
just said is part of the answer to that
question
well so i think your point is is a great
one that this is very stylized in i
guess two respects one is knowing the
boundary and two is knowing where you
are
right so like you don't know what
features are being used you don't know
where you are in it either right so um
although it's interesting actually i
remember when my kids were applying that
some of the state schools at least
it was actually you know you just need
to get this score on this test right
so it's there's a kind of nice feature
about that about knowing whether you
made it or not
you know in advance but but you're right
you don't know and you know and what
does it even mean like you know you're
the essay that you're writing like what
does how do you you don't know
how that's being viewed and how it's
being scored so you see you're right
kind of a more
um
yeah this is very stylized and uh and in
some sense actually models where
people don't know are maybe almost
easier to deal with because now
people will just manipulate as much as
they can
maybe
maybe okay
um anyway
you're right this is not realistic in
that sense
absolutely i completely agree with you
but the hope would be maybe maybe we can
hope to you know if we get some good
algorithms to incentivize decision
makers to be more transparent which i
think in general would be good although
you could argue sometimes it's not great
but i think in general it's good
so
i don't think i have anything smart to
say of it
i had uh one other question um
regarding the non-monotonicity and this
may have been something that you
addressed and i just missed the fine
details of
but when you were talking about the
result where it's like you can add a
target and actually reduce the overall
total improvement
how much of that is based on the idea
that someone always moves to the closest
target within their
ball in other words if there were two
targets within my little delta ball
and i could
and say we we added or there was only
one within my delta ball and you added
one closer to me
but i could still in principle go to the
further target which would say
improve my skill level which is a
continuous value more
if we instead assumed that agents go to
the furthest skill level
within their ability to manipulate
do we then get monotonicity back
yeah
yes so then you would get mods necessity
back so uh right so this does very much
that so that
that problem definitely it comes from
the the you know if we're going to think
about this as
i don't know
students are at different levels and
this is going to be what they need to
graduate or something like that and then
people are going to do the simplest
thing they can
right
then then it really is relying on that
or
but right if you could for example
you know if i give you a hundred dollars
for taking you know whichever test is
like i know where your location is and
you're only allowed to take tests above
where you are but but yeah it's right
it's a very particular model so
if you had a different model then that
that that could fix that problem
i guess we were initially thinking about
this in a context of you know maybe like
employees of the company and then you
want to set like promotion levels or
something and then you know and people
can maybe only be promoted one level so
between here and here is associate here
and here a senior associate here and
here is junior whatever and so
people would go up to the closest one
but yeah i mean definitely that um
if you change that that assumption that
would that would indeed address that
problem so you're right
completely
so again on the subject of uncertainty
uh so braverman and garg have this paper
where they argue that
having randomized classifiers
can
allow for
better strategic learning algorithms
have you thought about whether you can
gain anything in the perceptron setting
with
uh as opposed to a hard boundary between
zero and one probability being
classified having uh some smooth
now that's a great question and that's
right so so by um
there's a few things actually
randomization can do so
like in the braverman guard paper you
can if you have enough randomization
then maybe people won't strategize at
all because the cost to move
is uh
basically if the um the probability of
being classified positive if that's
lipschitz and kind of at a lower rate
than the effort then then it's why why
do the work right the probability of
getting accepted is going up by less
than the amount of effort then you won't
do it so that's one way but actually can
help in multiple ways
so in some sense one of the big
challenges is it you can't invert the
manipulation function
directly in our model you see where they
are you don't know where they came from
it's possible that with randomization
you could do that inversion because you
know
if they had started here they would have
moved a little farther here they would
move a little less then you can go ahead
and invert that and then use that for
learning so it does seem possible that
might help you know we
we weren't able to figure out something
but but definitely randomization could
really help yep
hi everyone thank you very much for the
very interesting talk
um i would like
actually um one of the questions was
connected with the previous one for
example for the classical perceptron we
have a smooth analysis framework what a
smooth analysis framework should say
about the strategic perceptor this is my
first question and my second question is
a little bit more open-ended i mean
from optimization framework
can we see somehow a black box where
we could
add in let's say that we want to
minimize a classification error can we
see somehow a regularizer that
could be added or a transformation in
the optimization problem
in order to
make it fair somehow to introduce the
fairness as a restriction this is a
second more opportunity questions thank
you
uh let's see so with the first question
so about um
uh
smooth analysis so uh right in the
standard case basically right what
smooth analysis lets you do is kind of
assume a margin even if they're maybe
the worst case data maybe doesn't have
much margin but with random
perturbations it's very unlikely that it
would simultaneously a be linearly
separable but by only say an
exponentially smaller right so
and so that's still true here um
it doesn't seem though that it
that the smooth analysis helps
you know
[Music]
helps a lot with the strategic issue
just because like the bad cases for the
standard perceptron if you'd move the
points a little bit it would the
algorithm kind of behave the same way it
wouldn't kind of
fix it so okay at least i can say that
for the standard non-strategic
perceptron a smooth analysis model won't
all of a sudden make it work in the
strategic case
um
yeah
the bad and the bad examples we have for
the strategic perception algorithm in
the case of hinge loss
uh i i don't think they are
very sensitive to the exact precise
locations
uh
so yeah i guess i would say it's it's
you you know always good to keep in mind
you know right because
but i i don't see it
addressing
i i could see randomization being a
solution to some of these i i just don't
at least the problems don't seem to be
ones that
that um
uh
smooth analysis would fix but you know
until you know a solution you don't know
right so so yeah and the second question
uh so regularizers for fairness um yeah
i mean actually it's interesting because
one thing is that normally regularizes
or things kind of you do um well i guess
they you apply them to i mean maybe
maybe there are you know basically what
you're trying to do is
uh
weight yourself towards certain kind of
solutions and keep yourself away from
other solutions in a smooth way and
yeah maybe um
uh
okay it's a vague question so i'll give
a vague answer maybe how about that
so i don't really i don't really have
much to say
okay great
uh
yes okay hi everyone uh great talk thank
you again
i have i have a question actually uh
and maybe it's a question about the
framework so in this in this kind of
framework it's a necessary component is
that i announced somehow like my my
decision algorithm right this is allows
for the for the participants to
strategize but it seems to me that like
uh such a commitment would introduce
almost invariably a new strategy
component like competition between
different
service providers so if i'm a bank and
you say oh
i provide i i got i guarantee loans for
everybody that has at least this
whatever instead of characteristics and
i'm bank of america i mean the next day
i'm citibank and i'm saying like oh you
know i'm going to give you a better deal
so by the way bank of america i won't
see a single client because my new
advertising campaign is that whatever
they offer i'm i'm offering a better
deal right and then the will not lead to
a kind of like bidding war
uh and then how does that
affect uh
affect this this calculation
yeah i
i don't know uh so i mean you're
thinking now it's a game among the
agents i guess there's two aspects of
that but maybe partly it gets back to
randomization which is you know it may
be that if you're going to if you have
to announce something maybe that thing
should be a probability distribution
that's one way
of
just in general in games you know
i mean i guess okay yeah i don't know i
mean normally when we have games we kind
of do sort of imagine that each player
knows what each other is doing that's
sort of the equilibrium notion in the
game
but but other hand we do typically think
of you know mixed strategy equilibria um
so yeah i don't really know and i kind
of wonder
with whether people would like like this
random is okay actually this brings up
another issue so while randomization may
address some of these things like i'm
not sure that people would view a
randomized rule as transparent like
would you like it if kind of okay in
order to get an a in the class you need
to either you know with 90
i'm gonna flip a coin see
and uh you know based on how the coin
comes out you you might get an a or a b
depending on i'm not sure people be too
excited about that uh but on the other
hand you know
maybe just depends on the context right
since
um
yeah i'm not so maybe randomized
solutions really you know uh
okay so so i guess why i might get into
that yeah so you're definitely right
you're bringing up
an issue of the game theoretic aspect
and yeah i don't i i don't really have
anything to say there and i i
if if randomization is actually an
answer to some of these problems here
even if it's just the decision maker
versus the entities being decided on
it's going to be even more of an issue i
think when there are multiple agents
making alcohol
yes i think we have one last question
thank you
sorry this is just a quick question
about a possible selection issue and i
may be misunderstanding but in the like
simple strategic perceptron case when
i'm a bank giving out loans i only
observe
whether you paid back the loan if i gave
it to you and similarly i only observe
whether you would not have paid back the
loan if i give it to you now because
perceptron only learned from its
mistakes there's only a problem if
like you would have been positive but
you were negative i'm just wondering
whether the strategic perceptron
would work
in that setting where i kind of
miss all of the positives that i
misclassify as negatives which i think
is accurate to like the loan setting
okay that's a great question so
basically
we've been operating in what's the
classic mistake bound model case where
after you make your classification
decision
you are told the right answer
and
um
and what you're talking about is what's
sometimes called the apple tasting
setting where if you don't taste the
apple you don't find out if it was good
or not right you don't give out the loan
you don't know if you made that mistake
or not
and that's a great question and we did
not consider that model
um and yeah that's a that's a really
nice question because a lot of results
for standard online learning do
translate over to this apple tasting
model and the regret bounds and all
those things
where you know basically
the algorithm is
what you do is you take your standard
algorithm but instead of classifying
negative well with some small
probability you class you taste the
apple anyway so classifying negative you
convert to well ninety percent chance
negative ten percent i'll give them out
the loan anyway just to get that
information and that ten percent will
drop to zero over time it'll be like a
one over routine kind of thing and
that's the sort of thing you'll do to
get those statistics maybe i don't know
when
maybe root t or t of some power anyway
you'll drop at some rate to get that
statistical information
and i don't know if that would apply
here that's a really good question i
don't know the answer
thank you
great
let's thank everyone again of the great
you